le traité sur le commerce des armes sous
l'égide de l'onu est entré en vigueur en
décembre 2014
après six ans de négociations
diplomatiques la communauté
internationale se dotait ainsi d'un
instrument juridiquement contraignant
pour réglementer le commerce des armes
classiques dans le monde
cela inclut par exemple les systèmes
d'artillerie les missiles des chars de
combat sa viande chasse mais aussi les
pièces et composants les états qui
joignent le traité s'engage à être
transparent et à ne plus fermer les yeux
sur les transactions d'armes qui
pourraient être utilisés contre des
civils ou violé des droits de la
personne
si près d'une centaine de pays ont à ce
jour ratifié le traité
le canada n'en fait toujours pas partie
puisque l'ancien gouvernement de ciment
plus s'y opposer voilà maintenant un an
que les libéraux ont déposé le projet de
loi c 47 pour permettre au gouvernement
d'ajuster ses doigts en vue d'adhérer à
ce traité